mà đen là đen thầy điều bật lý mà cái lịch nên của mấy anh dịch là thầy điều chật chật chật
mấy chật mà chật thì chỉ có thầy điều bật lý hợp
Họ bệnh đỏ mắt nổi tiếng với nhẹn dạ nạ vô
Mắt nổi tiếng với nhẹn dạ nạ ngờ hai mắt nổi tiếng với nhẹn dạ nạ vô
Mấy số chỉ có ăn bệnh chính là cứu nổ dòng điện hi, trạng qua rơ môn trạng qua rơ 2 bạm trạng qua rơ môn
Mọi người không thích kế này cũng nằm nổi tiếng mật chính
Mấy kế này cũng nổi tiếng mật chính, mấy nó cứ nổ dòng điện của mật chính
Mấy vô nào thì em bị chiếc đâu về chật đứa nốt, em mới vô ha dầu của bật lại ở đây thì bệnh chiếc chật chật này
Bệnh ở đây theo linform dùng 11c rentalEllie lấy 1, 2 đầu bạm mà ai bếp chiếc rồi điện chật
Ha bếp số, hai bế hà chỉ cho anh 6, đỏ em vẫn mới tính cho thầy vằng vào v業
Nat số cương bộ rẳng biệt i dứng ra bằng 4 amper nhé
Vậy chỉ kinh đồ vô ăn bát tế này
Chỉ số đó là vô ăn bát